Donna doesn't like the fact that Dagan
is lying about becoming one of his
victims so he confronts him at a book
signing in fact this must be 2005
entirely based on the fact that John
Kramer is swearing a backwards hat at
the age of 51. or maybe the backwards
hat is to indicate that he's a rebel and
he would soon demonstrate that remember
how his healthcare insurance provider
told him he couldn't seek outside
treatment he goes ahead and does it
Anyway by seeking out that Norwegian
doctor Dr Cecilia Peterson she has a
program outside Mexico City after going
through an operation scans revealed that
the tumor was never removed they only
pretended to cure him Jon puts each of
the people involved in the scam through
a new game